بينما يحشد الجيش الإسرائيلي على
الأرض، يطلق العنان لضربات جوية جديدة
على أهداف حماس في غزة ويفرض
حصارًا على الوقود والموارد الحيوية الأخرى،
ويغطي مراسل سي إن إن بن ويدمان
كل شيء لنا، إنه في جنوب لبنان
من أجلنا الآن بن
الأزمة الإنسانية في  يبدو أن غزة تزداد سوءًا
كل
ساعة حسنًا في الحقيقة وولف الأمم المتحدة
تصفها بأنها وخيمة وأعتقد أن الأمم المتحدة
أه بالأحرى تقلل من شأن الحالة تبدو
بكل المقاييس أنها
كارثية بالإضافة إلى حقيقة
أن عدد القتلى في غزة  لقد
تجاوز
النظام الصحي الآن 1500 شخص بكل المقاييس،
ووفقًا لوزارة الصحة الفلسطينية
فهو في حالة انهيار، فكل
الأشياء التي تحتاجها لتشغيل المستشفى ينفد
ببطء الوقود اللازم لتشغيل
المولدات التي تحافظ على
تشغيل المستشفيات والإمدادات الأساسية من الأدوية.
ببساطة لا يتم تجديدها
وبالتالي نرى أنه على سبيل المثال
في المستشفيات في جميع أنحاء غزة
يتم وضع العديد من الجرحى ببساطة على الأرض
والممرات لا توجد أسرة متبقية في
غرف العمليات تتجاوز أه
طاقتها الآن وفقًا
للأمم المتحدة  هناك 50,000 امرأة حامل
في غزة لا يحصلن الآن على
الرعاية الصحية جزئيًا بسبب القتال
ولكن جزئيًا لأن العاملين الصحيين
وجميع المرافق تركز
على علاج أه الجرحى يتحدثون الآن
عن الجرحى في وقت سابق من هذا المساء
زميلنا كريستيان أمانبور  تحدثت مع الدكتور
رانوس، وهو طبيب فلسطيني بريطاني
يذهب إلى غزة بانتظام وقد
أجريت معه مقابلات عدة مرات أيضًا في
غرف العمليات بينما كان يقوم بالفعل
بإجراء عمليات جراحية للجرحى ويقول
إن من بين الجرحى 30 إلى 40٪
منهم أطفال  وبالتأكيد هناك
إحساس في غزة أه في هذه
المرحلة الناس يشعرون أن المدنيين العاديين يتم
التخلي عنهم ببساطة لا أحد يبكي علينا
ليس هناك فروسية لا مشاعر القلوب تموت
فقط الصدمات وتبقى أجزاء الجسم الناس
عمياء عن هذا  الناس لا يستطيعون العثور على طعام
في منازلهم وهناك
حالة اجتماعية صعبة للغاية في غزة، فوق
الحصار وكل هذا يحدث
بسبب الحصار أين يجب أن
يذهب شعبنا، لقد كنا محاصرين منذ 18
عامًا أين يجب أن
نذهب و  وبالطبع إلى أين يمكنهم الذهاب، لا
يمكنهم الذهاب إلى أي مكان، الحدود مع
مصر مغلقة، لا يمكنهم الدخول إلى
إسرائيل. تحاول الولايات المتحدة والقوى
الأوروبية الأخرى التوصل إلى
نوع من الممر الإنساني حتى يتمكن
المدنيون الفلسطينيون الذين يتعين عليهم
الخروج  غزة ولكن في هذه المرحلة لا يوجد
تقدم في تلك الجبهة الذئب بن، لقد
قمنا بإعداد التقارير لنا، بن شكرًا جزيلاً لك،
دعنا ننتقل إلى الجزء العلوي